let's talk about the ultimate face
remedy for both wrinkly and dry skin the
skin is the largest organ in the body
and anything you put on the skin gets
absorbed inside into the body eventually
through the liver and it's amazing what
types of things people put on their skin
I mean just all sorts of chemical
lotions and makeup uh you name it they
scrub the skin they sterilize it you
have friendly bacteria on your skin
right and uh if you sterilize it the
skin becomes red it dries out or
sometimes it becomes too oily so it's
very important to understand not to put
anything on your skin that could be
toxic compound that with pollution if
someone you know smokes secondhand smoke
or let's say you smoke and all that goes
into the body I mean you have fluoride
and chloride in Your Shower with it you
know hitting your skin you have the
Sun's UV radiation that damages the skin
and then on top of that you have all the
stuff that you eat you know and drink
like alcohol or
consumption of trans fats all that goes
into the body and it can greatly affect
the skin I think one of the worst things
for the skin is going on a low fat diet
because skin is mainly protein and fat
and I remember in practice when I would
see people come in that a low fat diet
even on the keto diet and they're on
lowfat as in the ideal protein where
they're using this low carb and
extremely lowfat diet and of course the
ingredients are very poor like I think
the
soy protein isolates as their protein I
notice very quickly the person starts
looking older not just their skin but
their hair they just age the more junk
food that we eat the faster the Aging of
our skin what is Alter processed food
well now they synthesize corn to turn
that into corn sugar or high frous corn
syrup so you have this synthesized
synthetic sugars you have these
synthetic starches right corn starches
and then you have something probably
even more deadly which is the oils the
seed oils highly
industrialized highly refined very
unstable oil that tends to create a lot
of oxidation in the body I mean it
creates inflammation in the inside of
the arteries and the organs and the
different tissues and what about on the
skin right the thing about these oils is
it gets lodged into our membranes and
our skin and it stays in there for two
and a half to three years and so when
you have too much of these seed oils
right that's Omega 6 okay and not enough
of the omega-3 oils that's like fish
oils or Civ oil you start developing
flaky dry red skin because they both
compete with each other and I'm talking
about like soy oil corn oil canola
cotton seed oil safflower oil sunflower
oil these are all highly processed oils
with they use solvents like hexane they
deodorize it de coloriz it I mean a lot
of these omega-6 oils like like
sunflower oil for example are in creams
facial creams it's going to dry out your
skin it's going to make your skin older
so you also want to make sure there's no
alcohol in your skin creams so in the
last 100 years uh we basically have been
increasing the seed oils in our diet to
a factor of,
1600% more even in the last 20 years
we've doubled the amount of seed oils
highly inflammatory oxidizes the skin in
fact I'm thinking about doing like a a
30-day uh seed oil detox I'm going to
call it an oil change right just to see
how many health benefits would happen
not just with your skin but the whole
body by just avoiding these oils for a
short period of time what would be the
thing to put on the skin well are you
sitting down for this grass-fed toow
that's actually beef fat now before you
click off just hear me out it might
sound disgusting but the chemistry of
taow is very similar to the chemistry of
part of your skin in fact the Latin word
for taow means sebum that's like the oil
that your body produces the skin oil
taow will not oxidize the skin it will
not cause inflammation it has vitamin A
d e k it also has something called CLA
which tends to retain moisture in the
skin and T is not like coconut oil which
will make your skin really greasy and
oily it gives your skin a very nice
softness a healthy glow and a lot of the
nutrients in this taow can also help
some of the dark spots as well in the
skin and help wrinkles you should just
try it for a week and just see what
happens now as far as the type of fat
that's in here you have about 50% of its
actual saturated fats you also have
oleic acid
okay which is a really good moisturizer
you have ptic acid which softens the
skin you also have steric acid which
repairs the skin and then you have
linolic acid that's at Omega 6 but it's
only like 2% so it's very very small
numbers so I'm not recommending a
certain brand of taow but um you can
just look at the reviews and and just
read what people are reporting but you
start using taow on your skin instead of
regular chemical moisturizers with
omega-6 oils and you're going to see a
huge huge change and there's no
chemicals in it and it's kind of a
forgotten secret because we used to use
this long ago but then we replaced it
because someone came up with this idea
that oh saturated fat is bad for us no
unsaturated fats in the quantities that
we're consuming them and then the type
of these unsaturated fats that we're
using is just so unhealthy so if you did
the combination of two things just get
rid of the these Omega six seed oils out
of your diet and you start using t on
your skin and you start consuming uh
fish oils or codiva oil for the omega-3
within a matter of weeks I think you're
going to see a huge shift in your skin
so go ahead and try this and then
comment down below and if you have not
seen my video on how to address dry
wrinkly hands I put that video right up
here check it
out